Today I came to work by car.
In the future, this will surely
be very different.
I’ll be brought to work
by a self-driving car.
My name is Alexandre Nogueira.
I am a Computer Engineer,
and study Self-Driving Car Engineer
Nanodegree at Udacity.
My first job was at Ericsson
and I’ve been working there ever since.
I worked with system development
and project management,
and lately with new business
development.
After many years, I was working
at Ericsson as a consultant,
and I became a father
to two little girls,
and my life changed quite a bit.
When they grew up,
I discovered I had
a lot of time on my hands.
I decided to fill this time
by going back to school.
I was very interested in
Udacity’s Self-Driving Car program,
and I thought that it was time
to have a technical understanding
of how self-driving cars work
to be part of this revolution.
I haven’t stopped studying since
and have discovered that studying
is a great career booster.
The knowledge I develop here
with Udacity’s Nanodegree
allows me to help the company
develop new businesses
in other emerging areas.
I am also learning
about new possibilities:
What can we provide the market
that is definitely technically
grounded?
When you understand something
that is very advanced and complex,
it allows you to work
with simpler things more easily.
Self-driving cars will bring
more ease,
they will provide new services,
and most likely, they will give rise
to new markets
that we can’t even begin
to imagine right now.
With more efficiency and simplicity.
This will surely improve
people’s quality of life.